I like my hands are condescending yeah
you're short you shop at the Baby Gap
got in an argument with my boyfriend
this morning I love getting in arguments
about very major issues over very small
things he woke up and he's like I want
some breakfast and I go get a [ __ ]
banana shut up and he goes in the
kitchen gets a banana he's like hey Q do
you have any other bananas cuz this one
just got like the brown spots on it so
I'm like so you don't want the banana
cuz it's got some brown in it it's got a
little brown problem the brown in the
bananas says that's prime whew he's like
no no I'm just saying like I just wanted
to know if you had any other bananas
because if you had some other ones I
would choose those oh so you want
another bananas you want another banana
bow-wow-wow you got a banana right there
when the Netflix account but you want
another banana that's crazy
Wow Wow he's like you know you're
tripping listen I just wanted to know if
there were any riper bananas in your
kitchen
oh so you're telling me if the banana
had double d's then you'd want that
banana
and emanating and bother you why you
wanted to watch SportsCenter you'll want
that bananas that what you told me sigh
Quincy's your period way to the [ __ ] out
right now the real fun in that joke is
that boyfriend I want to ride people
were gonna ride but yeah I'm trying to
do the dating it's really hard I wanted
not becoming really good friends with
all the guys I think like I like them
and they like me but they never make a
move so we just become good chums that's
it
my guy friends told me Quinta one day I
want my daughter to turn out just like
you and I was like so should I grab that
dick now or later it sounds like you
wanna pro cream oh girl he doesn't like
me like that cuz I know one since
college anybody said something if he did
oh let me call you back all right bye
hey good nice jacket you got on there my
favorite part is when he takes the
toilet seat out and then right goes to
the wheels pop up only leo what I love
about that movie is the part where like
he's about to get caught he knows he's
about to get caught yeah but he almost
like wants to get caught but you also
wants to keep running right because
that's who he is that's just who he is
you know that's a great movie that's why
I need to make a new catch me if you can
Loki one of Leo's festivals first of all
he plays like a bunch of Ages occasion
do you know how difficult that is it's a
beautiful film beautiful piece of
Awesome
okay now on to another beautiful piece
of work for a three minute Internet yes
video I'm the super easy super simple
super short you'll be able to get it
it's real quick look at this guy over
here oh my god how could you need
anything at yellow see I get what he's
doing the yellow is like a cautionary
thing
yeah nose want to get hit yeah reality
yeah he's looking like a target yep and
I can't help it like I want to you know
I want to hit him I want it so badly I'm
gonna have a car when I buy a car from
the dealership you use mine don't worry
about what you use my heat him with it
she's asking for it awful okay when do
you plan on shooting this Friday I'm a
bit four days from now okay
like I said super it's super simple and
you need to be able I can't what I just
can't
I'm so sorry I can't
turtleneck why is he stretching she
looks like a floating lemon head the
candy yeah I know the candy yeah I why
wouldn't I know about lemon heads did
you eat them in college I didn't really
eat him but I know I thought it was a
silly candy they have that him busting
on you and your filly about a vegetable
can how do you know I thought it was one
of those things like like some chips are
only infill I didn't know I thought no
honest I mean clearly lemon heads are
everywhere they they are and you're
right you're right well how are you
doing I haven't even been able to ask
you since we said yeah I'm good yeah I
have three auditions coming up I'm
pumped for them I'm excited I'm like
prepared and everything so you know what
you'll get them all three of them
yeah maybe and if you don't fumble yeah
welcome stare loss it is their loss
you'll just start a web series based on
the exact same concept and then take
their money thanks Quinta no problem ISM
and cynicism always appreciated my
specialties yeah it would be hard to do
this without someone like you you know
you're awesome um I was thinking maybe
we spend all this time with each other
and everything we could try oh my god
sorry um I forgot to tell you Tiana's
finally visiting like finally visiting
why are going to love her like I swear
cuenta you were going to love her I mean
I can't wait to see her but it's like
the one from 10 day from OkCupid once
for loved ones for sex my bed that's how
they are in my head I told her a lot
about you by the way she's really
excited to meet you you guys would get
along you really would you know well I
need some new girlfriends anyway so
perfect yeah I see you guys being
friends you know listen she's great
okay she's like I don't want to be in a
relationship though people in
relationships tend to lose their
memories here's what I mean I'm out to
dinner with a couple the other day and
they're just sitting across from me so
yeah we went out the other day and we
went to the movies even want to see this
movie what was the movie babe oh it was
x-men and we have to see x-men really
you forgot x-men you forgot you forgot
accident can they say it in the movie
they go we are the x-men so I just want
to know how you forgot that part
oh it's all good
haha I made a list of people I don't
trust mm-hmm yeah girls who called their
boyfriends dandy you don't need a friend
you need a therapist people have it all
together in their 20s what are you a
wizard I like that [ __ ] it's Rachel's
witness get out of here and then people
who lick the pin before they even start
to write with it your PIN liquor
poisoning trust Martin Luther King
though I just got real oh I do I really
like my Luther King like I think about
him a lot more than the average person
like and I prepared for Martin Luther
King jr. Day you know what I mean like I
hang a little Martin Luther King's
around you know Kate told me stop saying
that joke cause it's not nice to say I
hung Martin Luther King but I do I put
the one tinsel and I put him around the
house I love Martin Luther King he's a
great dude the thing that makes me sad
is about Martin Luther King is that I
think he never got to have a dream again
you know what I mean like I feel like he
woke up one day and he's like Oh Rodney
that's it for me Ronnie Ronnie right now
I just had a dream I saw a pelican
playing checkers with Marilyn Monroe I
don't care if she's around at that time
Marilyn Monroe right he's like done that
joint was weak everything you dropped
from now on has to be fired like you
can't drop any weak dreams from now on
if Drake was around back then he would
go through it from Rio Luther King
that's not a joke that's fact so that
you guys don't know me I've been able to
have a lot of success out here in Los
Angeles it's been great and like I'm
happy I have friends and family to see
it but the only person who cannot see it
is my mother my success means nothing to
her nothing nothing she doesn't know
what the Internet is still so it means
nothing and I her solution for
everything all she wants is for me to
come back home that's it it doesn't
matter what it is so there was no Larry
Wilmore Kent Larry Wilmore buy you a
ticket home technically yes he has the
funds for the summer work and it's
become a solution to all my problems
that's been a solution for it I told her
the other day I was cooking salmon I
called her I was like hey mom I'm making
some salmon she seemed to be in for 15
degrees or 500 what should it be
cuenta baby just come home Sun hits it
most recently I was doing my taxes and I
was late I had missed a year don't judge
I missed a year I call my home mom
mom I did not do my taxes what the hell
what's gonna happen is the IRS coming
how deep does it get is the federal
service going to get involved what do I
do it's April 20 [ __ ] 15th what do i
do mom Quinta baby just come home IRS
came to my door the next day they don't
play Quinta
[Music]
winter when said I'm talking to you yes
are you okay yeah I'm just trying to
figure out this wedding for the month
I'll be fine
we don't have any more money to spend I
mean I'm not asking for money
honey are you eating yes I'm eating like
an asset it is not that bad mom
that's food just come home okay just
come home
people treat being short like there's
something very very wrong with you like
it's a disability or something
it's how imagine racism is I don't know
I've never experienced I had a girl once
say to me oh my god quintal you're like
so short you get the handicapped thing
for your car I was like no did your mom
get one for having you I can't just get
the things we want to me this joke
they'll be told here tonight
the worst thing about being this short
is letting down child predators happens
all the time they walk past me on the
street oh hello little one how are you
doing
sorry to disappoint both you and your
mustache there but I'm 26 years old with
401k keep it moving get mad damn it what
are they putting in the water
no girl younger they text that other
child predator friends if you see a
small african-american girl walking
around she's not I repeat not under 18
Ford coupe child predators text when
they have a problem I get the community
like you they reach out to the any child
predators hi there alright alright oh
but you are you're not Robert it's okay
it's someone else no but I can be you
can be Robert how much how much what
nine Robert look up a you're not the car
was expecting much 200 $200 for a
Newberry taking me to African I'm going
on the street dude look you um you don't
seem to be Robert you don't even seem to
know who were works so I think I'm just
gonna use lift and said I'm not Boober
honey then why are you here
you think of the prostitute here we
don't need to label anything I'm not
labeling it I'm not it I thought you
were a kid looking for guidance or fun
wow you think I'm a kid I'll have you
know I'm 26 years old sir yeah not a kid
talking in you your dick all right get
the hell out of here Robert before I
call the cops on you I'm not Robert go
hello hey hey there little lady
Hey look at you looking so young okay
you are Quinton right man not a man I'm
26
just take me to Rite Aid please
hey that's it for me I'm gonna go there
thanks guys appreciate it
[Applause]
[Music]